[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga where the focus this week is on
the strained relations between Germany
and Turkey this after German Turkish
journalist Deniz you gel was released
from a Turkish prison after spending a
year in detention with no charges
brought
now many people here in Germany are
asking why did President Recep Tayyip
Erdogan let you jail walk free was a
deal of some kind struck and what does
it all have to do with turkeys military
incursion into northern Syria so our
question here on quadriga this week
Dennis you gel is free but what game is
Turkey playing and to discuss that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by Buland mume who writes on Turkey for
the Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung
he says freedom for dummies you Joe
doesn't symbolize a serious change in
Turkey unfortunately there is no place
for hope yet also with us is Michele -
man as a foreign policy specialist for
the weekly deep sight he lived for
several years in Istanbul and he argues
that Turkey is hoping for transactional
deals but values stand in the way of
closer relations with Germany and a warm
welcome to - Ulrika Herman author and
journalist with the berlin-based daily
the targets I talk or taxes it is also
more commonly known where Deniz you jel
worked for many years and Ulrika argues
that erawan wants to make sure he's not
fighting on too many fronts
he needs Germany because in Syria he's
provoking the Americans boomer let's
begin with you you are a friend of
Dennis you jel explained for us why his
case and his personality his person
became so important for so many people
in Germany
well actually we should start first at
the personality of Dennis vigil he was
one of the most ambitious most reliable
journalists in Turkey I mean as a
foreign journalist so he always his
stories were always made the the
government so angry so to silence him
they just created a case to put him in
prison but then as a as a person who has
two different passports he become one of
the symbol
about the tension between Turkey and
Germany actually he was kind of a
hostage took by Turkish government
against Germany
I mean his his arrest month had no links
with low and even his release has no
relation with low it was just a case it
was kind of a negotiation between two
countries and something happened behind
the curtains and he is now free okay
let's just hear what Dennis UGL had to
say he had himself to say specifically
about that point that Buland was just
mentioning here we go the funny thing is
I still do not know why I was arrested a
year ago to be more precise why I was
taken hostage a year ago and I also
don't know why I was released today
Buland you also spent time in a Turkish
jail only for a couple of days I know
but what insights did it give you well
it gives me that I've looked we always
read about the the bad history of
Turkish journalists they suffered a lot
in in Turkish Republic the thing is I
have learned it personally that your
government never forgets what you have
did before even if you don't have any
links with the goodness even if you
didn't take any role in the military
coup in the input they never forget your
your past what you did as a journalist
and misread one has a huge has a huge
fate and he never forgets about the
journalists and they always punish you
at the right time and after the pooch
they they use the poot to punish their
old enemies frightening and fascinating
Ulrika Haman you were work together with
Dennis you gel at the tatts where you
work presently what was the reaction of
your among yourself and your colleagues
to the news that he had been released
immensely relieved first as a newspaper
it was also a very stressful time
because of course it was very obvious
that we had to support Dennis went while
in prison so we mounted actions
free Dennis movement in order to get him
free so for us it was really a enormous
relief finally to be successful and to
get him free but at the same time and
that's something I'd like to add it is
of course tragic that why Dennis came
three other Turkish journalists were
condemned for life and now a life
sentence in jail you know it is a kind
of problematic of course we had to
concentrate on tennis because otherwise
you cannot tell if you want to get
someone free you cannot talk about
Turkey as a whole and about everyone
sitting in jail but at the same time of
course it is a problem that now everyone
focuses on Denis and the other Turkish
journalists that are in jail are somehow
forgotten hmm we shall - mum what's your
view on what can you tell us about the
connection between Denis you jel his
release and Denis you jailed a person
and the the current situation though in
Syria the the war the incursion that
Turkey finds itself in what's the
connection between those two
well at first sight I think there's
little connection of course but mm-hmm
if we look take the general picture of
how a Diwan and Turkey tries to mend
fences on the one hand and wage war on
the other hand in a year two years ago
the main focus of a Duan was Europe and
so far as he described Europe and
particularly Germany as the as the enemy
at the SS the adversary he stirred a
public opinion against Europe and
Germany with the war going on in Syria
things have changed no he is in a very
difficult position in with the Americans
arguing about the role of the Syrian
Kurds there was even the prospect of a
possible conflict between the US and
Turkey in Syria so there are lots of
problems at that front and add one since
I think late late summer fall last year
try to mend has to try to mend fences
with Europe and particularly Germany and
Denis you tell is his release is the
result of the house
in some way being used as a bargaining
chip again against the backdrop that
you've just described I think not really
I mean as far as we know and this is
what both the German Foreign Minister
and the Turkish Foreign Minister had
said there is no deal struck we don't
know more than this because both Foreign
Ministries and and governments don't
talk about that if we look at a longer
prospect if if he was a bargaining chip
for anything he is part of this
normalization process which turkey would
like to see happening on the one hand
and and of course what the Europeans
might return and and here I think we
need to focus especially for example on
things like the modernization of the
eu-turkey customs union which is
something where there's a lot of money
in for Turkey and mm-hmm which could
also really come as a relief to many
other financial challenges and political
challenges Turkey has mm-hmm Buland what
do you say about this question it's been
much discussed here in Germany about
whether Dennis you gel has been used as
a bargaining chip what turkey wants for
his release the German Foreign Minister
says there is no deal has been struck
and I'm wondering whether he's telling
the whole truth well the first thing I'd
like to mention is I'm very jealous I
mean because a country a whole country
and the whole ministers the whole rich
greedy wrong tried the government and
the government dates right to you know
rescue a journalist from a country you
know it's it's something that we have
never witnessed in our country in the
contrary our country is trying to put
much more journalists in jail so it's
really the thing that we need to admire
first but the thing is there's a still a
huge hypocrisy in the German government
like one year ago mr. Gabrielle told to
the press that Turkish government is
getting away from being a democratic and
the rule of low country he said it in
May 2017 and after dennis has been
released the same Minister mr. Gabrielle
taught to the press that a Turkish
government is always careful about
freedom of the judgement system from
their government so it's really
unbelievable and the things the details
that we have learned about
his release it shows us that there was a
huge negotiation and both both
governments they knew that then this
will be released the the government had
sent a private plane two or three days
before Denis has been released they
arranged the plane we learned from dpi
yesterday and we know that mr. Bonelli
oldham the Turkish Prime Minister when
he came to to Berlin before he met from
America he taught that I hope that Deniz
will recently will be so happy when he
got released and one day later the
prosecutor they prepared the indictment
and one day later he is released and two
days later the Turkish Prime Minister in
Munich in the in the security conference
he told that we are ready to produce a
common tank together with Germany
so unfortunately these small details
shows that there is wasn't and they miss
release we're so happy about it
really very America nothing just briefly
on the tank issue I think we are still
quite far from that because the commonly
produced tank is basically Turkey once
this once this Turkish tank and so they
can provide some things to that but the
main technical technologically advanced
parts would come from rheinmetall and
and i think we are still very far from
that kind of of an agreement because at
the moment it's it's politically you
can't implement you can't explain that
intermediary why that campaign is open
the question of the future but I think
what is what this what you've just said
shows is that it was purely political
the whole process to put him to arrest
him to release him it was all political
dealings and but but it all happens in
the framework of what the Turkish
government wants at the moment
normalization and and Gabrielle I think
he he played that game with the Turkish
government by said by saying quote
unquote independent judicial system of
Turkey was it ironic wasn't sarcastic
was it cynical I don't know okay let's
pick up on the point of normal
normalization Germany in Western
countries of
- sighs Turkey's a response to the 2016
failed coup tens of thousands of people
have been jailed many more have lost
their jobs in Turkey is reported to be a
world leader in the imprisonment of
journalists the authorities moved the
site of the trial of the Jew Murray at
journalists from the Palace of Justice
in Istanbul to a high-security prison
ATSA livery that's where Deniz you jail
was held in pretrial detention but the
defendants supporters turned out again
and again to protest what they consider
the anti-democratic policies of the
Turkish government
Achmed Sheikh is the best known
journalist among the defendants he's
been in jail for more than a year
another journalist Achmed Alton his
brother and four others were sentenced
to life in prison
just hours after you gel was released
how far has Turkey moved away from the
rule of law yeah that's the big question
how far as turkey moved away from the
rule of law and Mitchell was just
talking about the prospects of
normalization in relations between
Germany and Turkey
Jemma's Damir a very prominent green
politician with Turkish German roots has
come out and said normalization at this
point in time is absolutely not possible
is he right or again yes and I think
that's clear to everyone here in Germany
that you cannot Chancellor Merkel yet
but you know she tries her best
you know she's someone who never ever
escalates or tries to get ahead of
developments she is very very cautious
and of course it would be for her it
would be completely it would be
dangerous to somehow and sense add one
but I think at the same time everyone
knows that he is a dictator and that you
really cannot count on what he's doing
next and what Edwyn wants is that more
tourists come to come to the turkey I
think that's his prime aim that he wants
Germany to issue its own inhabitants
that they can it
travel safely to the to Turkey because
turkey really needs this money from the
German tourists and many of the tourists
stayed at home because they were afraid
of Turkey and of course the whole issue
of Tennessee Jail daily it made it clear
to the Germans that is somehow unsafe to
travel to Turkey I think that's the main
reason why dennis was finally released
to somehow pop-up business mm-my we've
seen meetings between Angela Merkel and
there and the Turkish Prime Minister
we've seen meetings between two foreign
ministers they engaged in a tea ceremony
effectively together that sounds like
normalization to me well it sounds I
mean that's that's what the politicians
do I mean the thing is we as journalists
we need to tell the realities I mean of
course I would never ask or wait that my
country would have huge problems with
Germany of course these two countries
should work together they have long time
in history I mean that like more than
three or four million people living in
Germany Turkish origin people that's
quite good the relations should be good
but the thing is we shouldn't get used
to the politicians hypocrisy we should
always force them to confess to talk
about the realities I mean when Deniz is
free we shouldn't think that everything
is okay everything got normalized
between two countries and we shouldn't
tell the scenes of the Turkish
government what they're still doing
shall we keep silence no we should still
continue criticizing them but what's
really happening nowadays especially in
the German government is they stop
criticizing what's really going on in
the country like divert a picture to by
DPA and untold an agency which shows
that at a tank produced by Germany was
used in Syria and they showed that
picture to the to the to the press guy
of the German government and he said
that we don't have any information if
these low part tanks are being used in
Syria or not but there are still
pictures even there is the reality they
are trying to not to talk about it but
that's that's really the nasty face of
the politics and when you talk about
realities just tell our audience a
little bit about what the situation is
like for you on the ground in Turkey
because you are a fiercely critical
journalists working criticizing the
Turkish government and
in Turkey what's that like well it's not
easy actually when you are sitting and
your desk and try to type your you're
try to type your article you always
think that after a couple of days and
when you're when your story is when your
column is being translated and published
in Germany they can knock your door in
in the middle of tonight it that can
happen
you don't feel yourself free to write
everything but the thing is so much to
should do that I mean even my very close
friends are in jail now and we should do
something for them they're not outside
and they can try to we should do the
realities that and the ground the
problem is they silence the whole
community I mean they always think that
we put that journalist in the jail and
okay that it's nobody will be able to
criticize that the actually putting some
Jones in the jail is the message to the
rest of the media so the rest of the
media are frightened not to write
anything about that we don't have any
mainstream media in the country that's
the biggest problem in Turkey now to
Manisa is rajab type era when a dictator
if we lo if we talk about dictatorship
we talk about a concept of the twentieth
century I think I I think what he is
doing is he's establishing and strongly
authoritarian system with some
democratic declaration so he insists on
he's having elections and he but by
having elections he makes sure that he's
going to win these elections entirely he
you still have so every time you say
dictatorship then somebody comes along
and says well but there there are
newspapers which are still reporting
more or less freely but of course these
newspapers are insignificant so that is
basically what we today call a hybrid
autocratic hybrid authoritarian system
that's what we have so and that leads me
to that point where we were just talking
about the normalization question I think
this is the reason why there can't be
any near normalization because what we
have in Turkey is the end is the total
absence of the rule of law Germany is a
state with the rule of law
and that is why these two states are to
a certain degree incompatible and this
is the reason why I think in the future
we'll have lots of problems precisely
because of that because turkey is asking
for the extradition of Turks living in
Germany Germany won't do it all these
kinds of things so we will run off nude
into numerous problems because of the
said that mismatch of the two systems
mm-hmm
well we've mentioned already that
president Erdogan has ordered a military
offensive in northern Syria it's getting
a lot of backing back home in Turkey a
lot of international criticism here are
some images of what's going on turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan portrays
himself as an uncompromising defender of
national unity and he will do whatever
it takes to block Kurdish demands for
more autonomy air Dewan has also vowed
to crush terrorist groups that he claims
threatened Turkey's sovereignty
Turkish troops continue their offensive
against a Syrian Kurdish rebel group
called the YPG but the u.s. considers
the YPG a key ally in the fight against
what's left of the Islamic state
organization the Alliance's among the
states involved in the Syrian conflict
are constantly shifting his Iran leading
turkey into international isolation
let's pick up immediately on that
question or recur is is president heroin
leading turkey into international
isolation well he is leading turkey into
a confrontation with the US but at the
same time he counts on Russia
that's very office that he'd now is
somehow the that he thinks that his
biggest ally is Putin but at the same
time of course in Turkey is the week
apart Putin is the one who says what is
happening in Turkey has somehow to obey
but that's at this point I think the
best option add one thinks he has
because he wanted to have a war in order
to somehow have a good news for his own
domestic base because at home they have
big economic problems and the economy is
collapsing there's a high unemployment
so he needed to somehow put himself into
the role of a big war hero so that was
all it was about
how is turkey status as a NATO member
affected by the the crackdown at home
and the military incursion abroad so he
is a values-based
alliance it's a values-based alliance
status what basically the wisdom of the
past 10 years or so if we look further
back into history of course we had
examples like Portugal and the Salazar
or we had Greece and Turkey for that
matter during their coup times nineteen
sixty seventy eighty so that is NATO has
always been an alliance of members with
some some doubt about credentials and
that matter but here what were we
face is the problem of Turkey and the US
on two sides of the battle battle trench
and in Syria and that is a problem so if
we will come I think the the visit of
foreign minister Tillerson in Ankara has
led to some easing of the tensions
between the US and there is an agreement
that they don't want to confront each
other on the battlefield but I don't
know for how long that lasts and all
depends on how far and and where add one
will turn his tipster so if he goes in
the direction of min beach town in
northern Syria Kurdish controlled with
US soldiers I think we'll definitely see
a confrontation because these so-called
adults and the room in Washington the
the ministers of dominant resident Trump
they are not willing to concede this
kind of control because it's the last
stronghold of the u.s. in Syria so that
might then have effects after all on it
might have effect after all also on NATO
but we are not there yet I think he
would never risk it because they're not
he everyone knows that Trump has no
personal interest in Syria and that do
he will not engage in Syria but of
course if if ad1 attacked US soldiers
then Trump being a matchable just as
Edwin would no longer tolerate that and
you know it and I think that's something
I don't really understand I think he
knows what Trump is like because he is
like Trump himself so he would never
ever attack you're right but mind you
add one did that mistake with Russia
once you shut down a Russian aircraft
and you know I have no trust in this man
it's realpolitik but let's see yeah well
everything is based on the elections in
the end of 29 this is the stepping stone
the reason that our government and our
army says that
the Kurdish guerrillas they are linked
to PKK and their thirst organization so
we need to demolish them that's that's
kind of understandable reason for
Turkish government but question is
recently for a couple of years this area
is in the in power of discouraged guys
why today why the Turkish troops today I
started a war there and it's all about
the lectures in 2019 and the all polls
show that before that the operation
again suffering before that like before
Christmas we also that the the polls
show that his words were around 40 and
they were less than the last referendum
economic crisis international problems
they all create really unhappiness in
the country and he needed he needs a
nationalist victory to be able to be
like the Emperor of offering we know
that today that was a that was kind of a
story in a Turkish newspaper and a
columnist I wrote that if he cannot win
the first round in 2019 between two
elections he can open the third zone
conflict zone in Syria to be able to win
it so he can do anything to win that
election because it's kind of a race for
him he will he will be able to stay or
not in 2019 it's very important for him
okay we began with you Berlin Terry
that's one question I tried coughing
it's sort of a little bit of a tangent
and just ask you we talked we've talked
in the discussion about how dependent
turkeys on Germany Turkey is perhaps on
NATO membership how dependent is Germany
on Turkey there are hostages there
Turkey's a big NATO partner and of
course the refugee problem and the
refugee a refugee problem is number one
huge Turkish population here in Germany
and as you know that's right but the
poll that had been published by built
last week it shows that the the whole
the the fear in this country is getting
bigger and bigger about the refugees and
that held aft in this country so
anything happening in the country chains
or influence what's really going on in
the Germany - okay thank you very much
for those thoughts thank you all three
for being here we've been discussing
Turkey
Dennis you gel is free what game is
Turkey playing was the question we asked
I hope you given you we've given you
plenty of food for thought come back
next week
bye-bye untrue
[Music]